I started four businesses that cracked
10 million in a row I want to share the
Frameworks and lessons I learned from
the many mistakes that led to those four
in a row so that hopefully the next
business you have or the current
business you're on and Achieve that
level and Beyond so the first big
company I built was called gym launch it
was a licensing business for gym owners
as in I had a model and I would license
that model to them they would use those
things they'd make more money the
average would make an extra hundred
thousand dollars a year in profit
business at its peak was worth about 150
million dollars and then covid hurt that
business and I ended up selling it for
46.2 million to American Pacific group
which is a private Equity Firm out of
San Francisco the first 10 customers I
got from gym launch I got somebody to
pay a VA in the Philippines to scrape
crossfits database and then send me the
list of emails I then uploaded them to
Facebook made it look like audience off
of those marketed to get a webinar which
no one watched and then I had 80 leads
from people who had opted in and none of
them bought or scheduled a call and so I
looked up every one of the emails
manually and I like friended them on
Facebook I messaged them and then I got
a few of them on the phone to pay me 500
bucks to go out to fly to their gym and
actually do the turnaround once I
started the licensing version of the
model which is the one that really gave
me the scale I was able to sell
something that had virtually 100 margins
the first month I think I did like 120
000 in sales and the next month I did
like 300ish and then High fours and then
780 and all I was doing was just selling
more units and then we hit a million the
next month we would look at whatever
problems the gym owners that we were
with were currently suffering from so it
could be there suffering from churn or
they could be suffering from margin
issues they could be suffering from
they're not getting enough lead close
rates aren't as high as we want them to
be we would then create a hypothesis
around what we thought might work we
would survey the community and say who
has the best conversion rates if that's
what we wanted to fix and then we'd
invite 20 of them onto a call we would
take all the notes to figure out what
things they were all doing and here's
the important point we didn't say great
we're going to do all these things we
try to see the few things that they were
all doing then we'd say hey guys this is
a big deal this is like worth the cost
of change you're gonna have a
demonstrated long-term benefit to the
business for context my best gym did
about 600 000 a year our average gym
who's a gym Lord made six hundred
thousand a year big picture is that the
product has to be exceptional if your
customers are in love with your product
which takes more time because people are
like oh you threw this thing together
it's like it took six years for me to
put all those pieces together and then
finally be able to monetize that
deliverable and like that little inch
between good and great is yours but the
return you get on it from the word of
mouth that compounds is hard to Fathom
one of the other big secrets of gym
launch was that we had a very different
approach to acquiring customers the
traditional model of most businesses in
general is lost leader you know you get
someone in for some sort of free thing
you lose money on the acquisition you
make it up in LTV I came with a
different model and I've since done that
in every single business I have so this
is one of the important Frameworks that
I want to pass to you and it's something
called client Finance acquisition so
client finest acquisition basically
means you get the customers to finance
the acquisition of the next customer so
all you have to do is have enough money
to get the first sale and if you make
more in the first sale then the cost to
acquire that customer and the cost to
fulfill that customer plus the cost to
fulfill that next customer and the cost
to acquire the next customer you
eliminate Capital as a constraint in the
business you can put a dollar in and get
two customers back then that next
customer buys you two more and two more
and two more all my gyms were able to
just Crush everyone else because we
could outspend I've taken that
aggressive acquisition perspective to
every one of the businesses that I've
had we had many many terrible things
that happened during the launch I mean
one we had coveted which was tough you
know for gym owners uh in general a
third of all of our clients went out of
business another thing that we did that
was really bad was we over hired for our
support I had hired an inexperienced
director of customer service she was a
Frontline rep that we just promoted all
the way through I work ethic but no
experience and so she hired 35 reps and
we only needed five so we had to lay off
30 people and then that became a thorn
in our side for the next two three years
because our glass door got smashed the
biggest reason Jim launch was successful
one is that it was timing we identified
Arbitrage on Facebook ads before anyone
else did and we created a turnkey system
around how to monetize it I was running
ads on Facebook in 2013. you could put a
girl with a bikini and say click here
now like it was the wild the second
thing because of that Arbitrage the
average gym was taking home an
additional thirty thousand dollars in
cash in their first 30 days that was the
average if you take a business where the
average business owner is making thirty
six thousand dollars a year in profit
and then you add thirty thousand dollars
in the first month of working with them
you don't need to worry about marketing
technically my return on marketing was a
hundred to one for the first 18 months
in the business but it's because I
probably could have just not marketed at
all and I would have had the amount of
people that came in so like who knows if
the ads were doing anything but
everybody from the outside was like this
guy's ads are everywhere like he's
killing it so many people who are
copycats Mickey Mouse gimmick [__]
people who just used old versions of our
stuff to try and sell out of like all
the stuff you would imagine all those
guys went out of business because they
didn't have the deaf Prestige Labs was
my second big company which actually was
really a sister company to gym on you
built the whole thing of an affiliate
base that we acquired through gym launch
and so like the first month of being
fully operational did 1.7 million I
didn't want to sell supplements for a
very long time because I was like
supplements you just need to eat eat
right and work out this woman wouldn't
leave my office she's like my friend
says I need supplements like fine so I
wrote her list like go get this stuff
going she came back the next day with
the things and she was like I just want
to make sure I got the right stuff and I
saw the receipt and it's 700 on the
receipt and the thing that I had sold
her was 400 Baht and I was like [__]
that I'm gonna sell supplements so I
would recruit a gym owner and I would
say hey we're teaching you all this
marketing and sales stuff over here if
you just sell every person's supplements
it will cover the cost to acquire a
customer just from the physical products
and the Beautiful Thing with selling
physical products is that there's no
added fulfillment one of the problems is
the more you sell the more you have to
deliver right and so it's kind of this
double-edged sword where the moment you
swipe the credit card you're like oh
[__] now I have to deliver on this right
they didn't have to do anything they
literally just swiped the credit card
and then we managed centrally we would
ship it direct to the consumer I wanted
to create a brand only gym owner sold no
one else could sell it we priced it on
our home site higher we priced at 30
percent higher on the main side so there
were significant savings on top of that
we gave them a very good selling system
because I learned you know a lot about
selling supplements I made it a
recurring subscription so now they got
to have two recurring subscriptions per
customer I picked the first 10 customers
from distribution base already I rolled
out 10 locations and then the next month
I rolled out 20 or 30. next month I
rolled out another 20 30 and then we did
the big launch to everyone there's lots
of little things that we did that were
gym specific that no other supplement
company could do which has given us a
nice moat in that space cost me four
million bucks to start Prestige Labs
about a million of that went to the tech
so we created our an entire point of
sale for supplements that was
specifically made for Jim so every gym
would get a retail kit so they'd have a
full wall of products they would have a
kiosk which is a stand with an iPad type
thing on it apple-fi didn't really exist
that we had to build this whole thing
and then the other three-ish million
went into just product biggest
difficulties with it the supply chain so
like if you run out of one ingredient on
one product like you can't sell the
product there are also legal firms that
will buy all your products and try and
test to find something that's off or
unrepresented or whatever there's
predatory law firms that as soon as you
have a patent they'll just try and find
people to Sue and they'll just like
basically rev share all the amount of
money they can get the end consumer is
just not sticky and that's just because
people don't stick with Fitness stuff in
general for a long time so the biggest
lesson I have for you guys mosination
round Prestige Labs is that I probably
shouldn't have done it that's the
railroad it is a good business but I
think that if I had allocated more time
to just making gym launch better gym
launch would have been bigger and
because Jim won't stop growing the year
I launched Prestige Labs I just became
CEO of two companies rather than CEO of
one the third business I started use
allen.com still around today doing great
I saw where chat was going and I saw
where Ai and machine learning were going
a few years ago and I figured if I were
able to aggregate all of the data from
every single type of small business all
scheduling brick and mortar in-person
appointments I'd be able to predictably
show what days of the week what times of
day what kind of follow-up sequences got
the most amount of people to shop and
since we were compensating on percentage
of people that showed up we were highly
incentivized to solve that problem and I
learned a ton about how to get the most
throughput for leads and I've used that
in every one of the portfolio companies
that we have and you can usually add 20
30 40 to the throughput on ads simply
your scheduling process I first started
it to solve the problem for gym owners
because one of the biggest constraints
is that people don't work their leads
amazing I know um but the average gym
was getting nine percent of leads in the
door when they had to work them manually
we were able to get just under 20 of
leads in the door without them doing
anything and the average front desk
person costs 2 000 plus a month and we
could do it for a fraction of that sold
the first kind of customers of Allen by
going to our distribution base and
saying hey do you want to try this thing
what was interesting is that we very
quickly realized that we couldn't expand
outside of our distribution base the
Breakthrough was that I realized that we
needed to get agencies on board rather
than getting small businesses on board
because they'd be like great I can work
my leads how do I get leads and we're
like oh [__] they don't know how to get
leads so then we started selling
agencies which had another degree of
Leverage because if you saw an agency
they could have 50 small business owners
underneath of them I did two webinars
with people who had big agency audiences
so now you go up another level I could
make one pitch and in one pitch get a
thousand customers that was when this
thing really took off I did two pitches
and within six months we were doing 1.7
also ironically per month through the
software company Allen was the business
that I probably learned the most lessons
from I ended up selling that business as
well 75 of it to a strategic buyer who's
still running it and doing a good job
with it and hopefully they'll have a big
exit in a few years and that was an all
stock deal so under NDA I can't tell you
but I can tell you we did 12 million in
the trailing 12 months before the sale
that being said lesson one is that you
need to have an in-house CTO if you're
going to be if you're going to get into
software I developed software for
Prestige Labs I use the exact same
development shop to make the software
for Alan I regret that development shops
honestly they're as close to a complete
scam as you can come to because if you
really are going to build a software
company you need to build a software
company like that's it like you need to
build a software company it's like
having a marketing agency and having a
white labeled marketing agency doing all
your delivery it doesn't make any sense
number two is that you want to run
pricing surveys early because we
unlocked four times the pricing Power by
simply repackaging how we charge
exploring different ways to charge based
on usage based on recurring fees
different apis this is especially true
with software because there's so many
different ways you can charge compared
to maybe traditional service the third
thing is having aligned incentives with
your customers often just makes you more
money and so that business had a
tremendous amount of scale because we
had so much alignment with every single
stakeholder the small business owner
wanted people to show up the agency
owner wanted people to shop and we got
paid based on shops so everybody was
aligned top down the fourth thing
throughput on appointments when you're
scheduling for sales calls or in-person
appointments the amount of days per week
that you are open the hours that you are
open and the increments of time matter a
lot like 50 to 200 percent would be like
marketing doesn't work for me and they
had one time sought for an hour per week
that they were willing to take their
customers on that's just stupid there's
no other way to say it the people who
made the most money who had the most
throughput are the ones who gave the
most availability gave the most
flexibility their customers were open
the most days and they unsurprisingly
got more people to schedule and show up
there's a reason small business owners
stay small they make small business
owner decisions so acquisition.com so
this is the fourth business portfolio
companies that right now does over 200
million dollars a year and I make these
videos so that you can hopefully pass 3
million 10 million Etc and then we can
invest in your business to help it grow
from this I started with the question
what can I do forever and then work
backwards from there so it's like there
has to have a lot of Leverage I need to
have a capital company vehicle so the
first 10 Investments that we found some
people I knew from you know beforehand
and I would say that the relationship
had shifted more and more to like
basically an advisory role anyways and
the rest of it has been uh people who
read the book who watch videos who
listened to podcasts who come in who
already are aligned with our values
we'll always look at anything as three
or more but most the businesses are over
five the average business right now is
doing 17 million so acquisition.com is
the first business that was really like
built on a personal brand and inbound
with content so that's been like the
biggest change compared to the other
businesses there's pros and cons to it
like it's a slower business overall if
you are used to doing a transactional
business where you're doing multiple
sales a day going into a business model
where you have one every month is very
different and there's a lot of
conversations that happen that don't
amount to anything the thing that
excites me most about acquisition.com is
I learn more now than I ever have
because I'm exposed to more businesses
at a higher level I believe that the
purpose of life is to learn um that is
my purpose of life then enabling myself
to learn in as many ways as humanly
possible maximizes that so we co-own all
these businesses because I want to learn
how solar sales work I want to learn how
mortgage sales work like knowing a lot
about a lot of things allows you to
cross-pollinate ideas that work well in
one industry and then apply them to
another one and then get outsized
returns as we saw how quickly and how
easily acquisition.com grew the biggest
part of that was because we hired from
the top down there was so much that we
could automatically delegate to people
who were better than us at their
respective Things director of sales
director of marketing director of people
director of I.T director of portfolio
operations as good as but better than us
who are teaching us every other business
I've had I hired from the bottom up this
one I went from top down and I will
always do that from here on out you can
really only do that if you're well
capitalized that's why Venture people
raise money because you can get more
Talent before the business can really
afford the talent because at the end of
the day every business incurs debt it's
just what kind of debt so are you
incurring financial debt are you
incurring management debt cultural debt
technical debt and the question is which
one do you want to pick and have to pay
down later and so for us being the bank
was willing to pay down financial debt
to not have to pay any of the other debt
down in the future because ultimately on
a longer time Horizon we'd move faster
and the other thing is that we have made
recruiting Talent the single core
competency of the business most of the
companies that we're bringing on the
entrepreneur needs more talent and we
have the ability to recruit Talent
better than most people because one we
have so much inbound that comes in two
we as a private Equity Firm have more
Prestige than most of the companies that
are in our portfolio and so we can
recruit and people respond to a private
Equity Firm who has portfolio companies
more than they respond to Joe's dry
cleaning and then we have somebody at
holdco who will help train them on our
way of doing business so they get it
right the first time a portfolio company
when their managers are getting stuck or
their director is still getting stuck
they talk to our director of sales and
if you're a business owner and you'd
like to scale to 50 100 and Beyond we'd
love to partner with you on it we have
the track record that we have because
we've done it multiple times and the
biggest costs that you have in the
business is what you do not know and so
if we can help you pay down ignorance
debt and we can drag what you might
already do in 10 years and three years
then for us that's a win for everyone so
if that's interesting you can always go
to acquisition.com
go there apply through the site and look
forward to hopefully working with one of
you guys